it's six o'clock in the morning pitch
black outside my 14 year old son is fast
asleep in his bed sleeping the reckless
deep sleep of a teenager I slip on the
light and physically shake the poor boy
awake because I know that like ripping
off a band-aid it's better to get it
over with quickly I have a friend who
yells fire just to rouse her sleeping
teen and another who got so fed up that
she had to dump cold water on her son's
head just to get him out of bed sound
brutal but perhaps familiar every
morning I asked myself how can I knowing
what I know and doing what I do for a
living
be doing this to my own son you see I'm
a sleep researcher so I know far too
much about sleep and the consequences of
sleep loss I know that I'm depriving my
son of the sleep he desperately needs as
a rapidly growing teenager I also know
that by waking him up hours before his
natural biological clock tells him he's
ready I'm literally robbing him of his
dreams the type of sleep most associated
with learning memory consolidation and
emotional processing but it's not just
my kid that's being deprived of sleep
sleep deprivation among American
teenagers is an epidemic only about 1 in
10 gets the 8 to 10 hours of sleep per
night recommended by sleep scientists
and pediatricians now if you're thinking
to yourself whew we're doing good my
kids getting eight hours remember eight
hours is the minimum recommendation
you're barely passing eight hours is
kind of like getting a C on your report
card
there are many factors contributing to
this epidemic but a major factor
preventing teens from getting the sleep
they need is actually a matter of public
policy
see not hormones socialize or snapchat
across the country many schools are
starting around 7:30 a.m. or earlier
despite the fact that major medical
organizations recommend that middle and
high schools start no earlier than 8:30
a.m.
these early start policies have a direct
effect on how much or really how little
sleep American teenagers are getting
they're also pitting teenagers and their
parents in a fundamentally unwinnable
fight against their own bodies around
the time of puberty teenagers experience
a delay in their biological clock which
determines when we feel most awake and
when we feel most sleepy this is driven
in part by a shift in the release of the
hormone melatonin teenagers bodies wait
to start releasing melatonin until
around 11 p.m. which is two hours later
than what we see in adults or younger
children this means that waking a
teenager up at 6 a.m. is the biological
equivalent of waking and an adult up at
4 a.m. now in the unfortunate days when
I have to wake up at 4 a.m. I'm a zombie
functionally useless I can't think
straight I'm irritable and I probably
shouldn't be driving a car but this is
how many American teenagers feel every
single school day in fact many of the
shall we say unpleasant characteristics
that we choke up to being a teenager
moodiness irritability laziness
depression could be a product of chronic
sleep deprivation for many teams
battling chronic sleep loss their go-to
strategy to compensate is consuming
large quantities of caffeine in the form
of beta frappuccinos or energy drinks
and shots so essentially we've got an
entire population of tired but wired
youth
advocates of sleep friendly start times
know that adolescence is a period of
dramatic brain development particularly
in the parts of the brain that are
responsible for those higher-order
thinking processes including reasoning
problem-solving
and good judgment in other words the
very type of brain activity that's
responsible for reining in those
impulsive and often risky behaviors that
are so characteristic of adolescence and
that are so terrifying to as parents of
teenagers they know event like the rest
of us when teenagers don't get the sleep
they need their brains their bodies and
behavior suffer with both immediate and
lasting effects they can't concentrate
their attention plummets and many will
even show behavioral signs that mimic
ADHD but the consequences of teen sleep
loss go well beyond the classroom
sadly contributing to many of the mental
health problems that skyrocket during
adolescence including substance use
depression and suicide in our work with
teens from LA Unified School District we
found that teens with sleep problems
were 55% more likely to have used
alcohol in the past month in another
study with over 30,000 high school
students they found that for each hour
of lost sleep there was a 38% increase
in feeling sad or hopeless and a 58%
increase in teen suicide attempts and if
that's not enough teen to skip out on
sleep are at increased risk for a host
of physical health problems that plagued
our country including obesity heart
disease and diabetes then there's the
risk of putting a sleep-deprived teen
with a newly minted driver's license
behind the wheel studies have shown that
getting five hours or less of sleep per
night is the equivalent of driving with
a blood alcohol content above the legal
limit
advocates of sleep friendly start times
and researchers in this area have
produced tremendous science showing the
tremendous benefits of later start times
the findings are unequivocal and as a
fleet scientist I rarely get to speak
with that kind of certainty teens from
districts with later start times get
more sleep to the naysayers who may
think that a school start later teens
will just stay up later the truth is
their bedtimes stay the same but their
wake up times get extended resulting in
more sleep they're more likely to show
up for school school absences dropped by
25% in one districts and they're less
likely to drop out not surprisingly they
do better academically so this has real
implications for reducing the
achievement gap standardized test scores
in math and reading go up by two to
three percentage points that's as
powerful as reducing class sizes by
one-third fewer students or replacing a
so-so teacher in the classroom with a
truly outstanding one their mental and
physical health improves and even their
families are happier I mean who wouldn't
enjoy a little more pleasantness from
our teens and a little less crankiness
even their communities are safer because
car crash rates go down a 70% reduction
in one district now given these
tremendous benefits you might think well
this is a no-brainer right so why have
we as a society failed to heed this call
often the argument against later start
times go something like this
why should we delay start times for
teenagers
we need to toughen them up so they're
ready for the real world but that's like
saying to the parent of a two-year-old
don't like Johnny nap or he won't be
ready for kindergarten
delaying start times also presents many
logistical challenges not just for
students and their families but for
communities as a whole updating bus
routes increased transportation costs
impact on sports care before after
school these are the same concerns that
come up in district after district time
again around the country as school start
times are debated and their legitimate
concerns but these are problems we have
to work through they are not valid
excuses for failing to do the right
thing for our children which is to start
middle and high schools no earlier than
8:30 a.m. and in districts around the
country big and small who have made this
change they found that these fears are
often unfounded and far outweighed by
the tremendous benefits for student
health and performance and our
collective public safety so tomorrow
morning when coincidentally we get to
set our clocks back by an hour and you
get that delicious extra hour of sleep
and the day seems a little longer and a
little more full of hope think about the
tremendous power of sleep and think
about what a gift it would be for our
children to be able to wake up naturally
in harmony with their own biology thank
you and pleasantries
[Music]